hey guys it's January 24th I'm chastity
and I'm way too afraid to keep playing
Resident Evil 7 and VR I got some motion
sickness when I tried it out and I've
never been more thankful for motion
sickness so I can get the hell out of
there but if you want to see some game
spotters playing Resident Evil 7 in VR
check out that video and do us a favor
and hit subscribe it really helps us out
and now the newest overwatch is Lunar
New Year event has begun with capture
the flag mode and tons of new items I
need all of those new skins all of them
Blizzard has fully unveiled everything
featured and overwatch is Lunar New Year
event which is now live on all platforms
most notably this event introduces a new
capture the flag style mode as a brawl
called capture the rooster this has
played out on an updated version of
li-jiang tower and forces players to get
creative with their team compositions as
they attempt to construct a lineup that
simultaneously built for offensive speed
and defensive stability Blizzard doesn't
intend to add it to the quick play or
competitive rotation at least currently
as with previous events standard loot
boxes have been replaced with new ones
lunar loot boxes come with a variety of
new items but these packages will only
be available for a limited time you'll
be able to keep and continue using
anything you earn between now and
February 13th making the earned or
purchase like standard loot boxes and
are guaranteed to include at least one
of the new set of items including skins
icons sprays emotes highlight intros
victory poses and more which new skin is
your favorite tell us in the comments
next up we've got details on battlefield
ones first paid expansion dice today
shared a lot of details about
battlefield ones first paid expansion
they shall not pass a post on the games
website outlines the new maps weapons
items mode and more there are four maps
in the french themed addon Verdun
heights fort vu sois on and rupture they
shall not pass also adds the French army
whose soldiers wear blue uniforms as
well as a new mode called frontlines
this is described as a mix of conquest
and rush in terms of vehicles they shall
not pass adds the chart to see tank
which is based on a real tank it is a
new behemoth class vehicle that dices
can be used to turn the tide of the
entire battle another tank the saint
shaman
is added with the expansion as well
while a new elite class called trench
Raider comes to the game a melee focused
class the elite trench Raider uses a
Raider Club and has access to an
impressive grenade Arsenal a new
stationary field gun the siege howitzer
is also included it can be fired by any
infantry player no release date has been
announced for they shall not pass beyond
sometime in March but people who own the
battlefield one premium pass can play it
and the other three expansions two weeks
before everyone else can buy them and
finally a wild Pokemon game appears on
mobile it's called Pokemon duel and it's
out now out of nowhere a new Pokemon
game released today on ios and android
called pokemon duel it's a free to play
strategy board game for mobile it was
released in Japan as Pokemon ko master
in 2016 but has only now been released
in English pokemon duel doesn't contain
the same rock-paper-scissors combat as
the mainline games instead it's a
turn-based board game in which you move
Pokemon counters to the opponent's side
of the arena clashes between friendly
and enemy counters result in a dueling
minigame duel does however retain the
collectible element of other Pokemon
games using in-game currency you can
unlock chests containing new Pokemon
counters for use in battle just a
reminder that the lobby has moved to
Wednesdays so go ahead and check that
out and chat with them live during the
show tomorrow Wednesday 11 a.m. Pacific
time I'm chastity and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]